la france est dans une position
intenable elle fait de l'ingérence oui
objectivement c'est de l'ingérence son
problème c' est l' ingérence mais la
solution au problème jihadistes c'est
l'ingérence aussi
de la république du mali informer
l'opinion nationale et internationale
que ses jours lundi 31 janvier 2022
l'ambassadeur de france à bamako son
excellence et jouer le meilleur a été
convoqué par le ministre des affaires
étrangères et de la coopération
internationale qui lui a été notifié la
décision du gouvernement qu'il invite à
quitter le territoire national dans un
délai de 72 heures la france doit-elle
abandonné le mali la tentation est
grande de laisser tomber le mali en
effet d'ailleurs la ministre de la
défense le ministre des armées florence
parle il a évoqué cette possibilité
pourquoi parce que c'est très difficile
de mener une intervention militaire dans
un pays où l'on ne veut pas de vous
actuellement la junte au pouvoir à
bamako
attise la haine anti-française la junte
et dans ses propres contradictions elle
elle a besoin d'un appui extérieur pour
lutter contre les djihadistes le colonel
goïta qui est le chef de la junte est
lui-même très engagé et c'est un
militaire qui a été très engagé dans la
lutte contre les djihadistes donc il
n'est pas en train de vouloir pactiser
avec les djélis simplement il
il y à une mésentente profonde entre les
autorités françaises et les autorités
maliennes issus de ce putsch le ministre
dit vous êtes irresponsable et
illégitime ce qui est objectivement est
assez vrai en tout cas pour lille
légitimité et les la junte répond
vous êtes hostile et outrageant ce qui
est vrai aussi en terme de langage
diplomatique le renvoi de l'ambassadeur
c'est un geste de mauvaise humeur public
la france est dans une position
intenable elle fait de l'ingérence oui
objectivement c'est de l'ingérence
son problème c'est l'ingérence mais la
solution au problème jihadistes
c'est l'ingérence aussi pourquoi la
france accepte tel cette humiliation
dans un intérêt direct la france le
mesure très bien si demain elle se
retirait totalement
ce qui n'est d'ailleurs pas très facile
à faire parce qu'on a des soldats sur
place et on voit très bien aujourd'hui à
quel point le gouvernement est modérée
dans sa réaction après l'expulsion de
l'ambassadeur de france n'y a pas de
mesure et de réciprocité prises par
paris pourquoi parce qu'on a des
militaires sur le terrain et même s'ils
sont moins nombreux puisque le président
de la république avait décidé de
diminuer de moitié le dispositif
français n'a toujours toutes ses troupes
sur place et réagir de manière trop
vives ou trop susceptible pourrait les
mettre en danger les intérêts de la
france ils sont clairs ils sont les
mêmes que ceux qui ont motivé
l'intervention au tout début c'est à
dire est ce qu'on veut un califat
islamiste du type de celui qui s'était
installé entre la syrie et l'irak
et le voir se déployer dans les
immensités sahélienne l'europe serait
directement concernées dans sa sécurité
si intel khalifa si un tel état
islamique
s'enraciner est-ce aussi la preuve d'un
affaiblissement militaire de la france
la france a une capacité de projection
la question c'est pour combien de temps
et avec quels soutiens la france elle
seule ne peut pas amener une guerre de
n'a pas les capacités opérationnelles
pour mener tout seul cette guerre sur
une durée aussi longue donc on a besoin
de l'aide des américains on a besoin de
l'aide des européens on a eu je crois
jusqu'à 15000 hommes dans la région on
était descendu à 5000 ont voulu on était
en passe de les ramener à 2500 peut-être
va-t-on le retirer ses 2500 hommes si
vraiment le mali n'en veut plus il
faudra continuer à se préoccuper du
problème mais d'une autre manière sans
troupes sur le sur le terrain ou alors
attendre que les maliens nous rappelle
au secours une nouvelle fois
[Musique]